most people's environments are designed
to keep them small not that they have
designed it themselves it has been
architected by others it's been
architected by your parents it's been
architected by whoever had the place
before you if you just change the
environment and that's what you consume
that's who you follow I was doing a
podcast today talking about how the
negative social media is it's like not
mine yeah I go to my Instagram and it's
amazing all positive I go to my YouTube
channel it's like awesome because I'm
not following people who are spreading
negativity you could easily go and find
lots of negative accounts to go off and
follow as soon as something negative I'm
swiping away I don't want that out in my
algorithm I don't want you feeding me
more of that crap like next Gone Gone
same thing for YouTube